what's going on there reject nation we
got ourselves a first look at the flash
aka the batman movie i'm very much
excited for this other bat other batman
movie no i'm really looking forward to
this dude i just uh reread flashpoint
finished it last night again i know this
is gonna be a hundred percent the same
thing it's gonna be exactly frank
adaptive frame for frame shot for shot
adaptation
it's about time yeah i know you're a big
flash fan i i mean he's my guy
optimistic speedy i made my own heart
and john uh i'm here in the video
[Laughter]
boston
make sure to subscribe click that
notification bell we have we're on the
lookout for that batman trailer got a
little special opening vid prep for you
guys and follow coijondro on the
youtubes and all that stuff guys let's
get into action people
[Music]
was that wayne manor at the top i think
you're right
are those two berries any time one
in the universe
oh my god
go save your mom oh yes
dude i love this suit
wow
just like to save this one
you changed the future
oh [ __ ]
dude
jersey
i love the new suits
[Music]
beautiful
show it do it do it come on show it show
it
they actually showed us more than i
anticipated i could not believe how much
was in there that was a lie it opened up
it kicked off with michael keaton and
wayne manor a voiceover of our oh yeah
that was
voiceover and two berries allen two
baryons out of supergirl right yeah yeah
so supergirl i mean confirmed visually
yeah okay but it seems like whereas in
like the flashpoint uh comic which i
read that's right i've read one comic
book
read what just one he like just for
today
what's up
but in there he doesn't learn that he's
the one like he's forgetting his
memories so he doesn't realize that he's
the one who created flashboard until
like little later on i don't know if
they're gonna do the mystery aspect to
this it seems like they're showing right
away that he's making the choice this is
what we're doing yeah seems like the
catalyst is i'm gonna go save my mom
we're probably gonna get a scene with
him and billy crudup uh so no ron
livingston oh they replaced him yeah
john you served a strong purpose
yeah so you're gonna you probably get a
scene with him and his father to help
motivate the situation um but then all
this craziness and soon so we got no ben
affleck here but we got a lot of michael
keaton so it seems like he really is
going to play an integral part here but
man that suit and you get the flash ring
this time around boy oh boy
[Laughter]
john before koi overshadows yeah
i was just really enthralled by the tone
of this i really liked just the sort of
build up that they have going this
intrigue that they're building and yeah
stepping back into the world of michael
keaton's batman i liked at least what
they showed us here because it really
did feel like you're stepping into a
relic something from the past and
something that's a little out of time
and then yeah having two barry allen's
they're both ezra miller in different
forms like this looks really cool and
out there and fun and i am really
excited based off this where i wasn't
necessarily before because like andy
muschietti i think he's got chops i
wasn't in love with it though this is
getting me excited for what this guy can
do well it seems like with the
cinematography when you're in you know
michael keaton's world that's reflecting
the tim burton yeah i love that and the
music is really cool koi john's take a
breather okay so what i think this
allows for is flashpoint in the comic
books is this great uh retroactive
reboot option you can do anything there
is no continuity because all continuity
is continuity this allows as they've
already done with having ezra meet
barbary allen and the cw universe grant
and ezra have met we can have this make
everything canon and every universe
possible now we can get a batfleck movie
now we can get the the deathstroke movie
now we can do any of this if things go
well so this really allows especially
leaning so hard in the michael keaton at
all he's navigating us through a world
where that could lead a batman beyond to
happen he's an older michael kane so as
much as i want the flashpoint story what
i love about this is it allows for
infinite possibility for the dc universe
what the dc universe has done so far is
they've gathered different corners of
their comic books they've made different
tonalities what i love is that all those
different tonalities you can't argue
that shazam and the batman looks similar
they're very different universes this is
a great piece a cohesive unit to make it
all one streamlined thing so we can get
infinite cameos in this we can get tv
cameos we can get movie cameos or none
at all and then wherever this lands it
branches off into something else and
what i really am excited about is the
ron livingston of it all allows it to
work because
like this is the only time they're like
man it's not like viveka's uh what's the
name will smith's mom and and fresh
prince where it's like i've noticed the
different moms here like this allows for
a lot of different options
from everything but you just chose fresh
princesses
from iron man 2
it works these are not fresh prince
faints well why not yeah let's go with
that fresh breakfast i really like that
there's an opportunity to make all
continuity universal and what i loved
most is the suit this suit
gorgeous the gold boots the suit looks
streamlined instead of the i do not love
the hard suit it feels not as
streamlined as the flash needs to be and
this feels like ezra is the flash which
i have felt on and off about like this
this trailer in a minute sold me and
they leaned so batman like this was a
batman trailer which we jumped right
before well it's still it's still very
it feels like a bad man like the flash
is going into the batman world you know
in all fairness this is a bargain for
flashpoint and that's what happens in
the comic it's strong look i mean yes
it's thomas wayne versus bruce wayne but
at the same time though he does go to
batman for help and it's him in batman
trying working together trying to solve
this timeline issue so especially after
i've been kind of on the cynical side of
like managed to feel like a batman movie
but after rereading the comic i'm like
oh wait this actually no this fits it
still feels like ezra miller is the lead
right and michael keaton or whatever
better it might feel like more of a
team-up movie exactly it might be like a
one-to-one except for one of the ones is
two people yeah because it's both
batfleck and mike keaton and i i just
think this i don't know this is one of
the most impressive teasers i've had for
those crazy neutral and mushy eddie this
looks like burgundy so instead of
teaming up with superman they'll team up
with supergirl yeah yeah and grant
gustin will show up that's it you might
what a great way to introduce supergirl
too this is uh as limited as my comic
book references will go for today no i
forgot it was time
you guys made fun of my fresh prince now
yeah so we're all at the definition the
joke is koi knows so much more than us
that it makes us feel like we know
nothing i tried to leave the world of
comics to get some fresh prince love in
there and i get this gum guys what did
you think about the trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click the
notification bell let's end this off
with a pic
what i also just thought of what if this
addresses michael go playing multiple
outfits for multiple batman remember
michael go played batman for both
michael keaton and val kilmer and george
clooney what if flashpoint allows us to
retroactively make the tim burton going
into joel schumacher batman's into one
batman through use of flashpoint this
could actually make the bat continuity
make sense through outfit i i
maybe
maybe
rosa parra why are you here still you're
really good top-notch critic now you
totally are out there on rotten tomatoes
and like your article that is dedicated
to you rotten tomatoes you're hosting
screening featured editorial critic fees
and i was like what what are you messing
around she keep piddling around with us
for she's joined her patreon page before
she even like started doing any of this
and now she has a far exceeded us
can you give us some tips right now i
feel like you're just throwing money on
what you're like here peasants to have
some of my my change that i got from the
grocery store
maybe my review prowess will rub off on
here with a few of these shackles you
gotta give to charity once in a while it
seems like they don't know what they're
doing here
where's the rosa para patreon that we
can subscribe to she doesn't need it man
she's just doing so well she doesn't get
out there
can you hook us up with passes to the
next screening that you host anyway rose
i'm happy for you
and you also puzzle me
don't get any bigger
for our sake
[Music]